Family Guy was the brainchild of voice
actor Seth MacFarlane centering on the
Rhode island-based Griffin family and
their various Antics its first season
was subject to good ratings in 1999 but
when its second season saw a decline in
2000 Fox abruptly canceled the show only
to revive it for a third season a few
months later once Family Guy struggled
to maintain high ratings for its third
season Fox canceled it yet again in 2002
and sold the rights to Cartoon Network
who began airing reruns of the program
on their late night Adult Swim
programming block it slowly gained more
attention from Adult Swim's audiences
and thanks to the additional sales of
DVDs Family Guy was revived by Fox for a
second time in 2004. Family Guy has
remained a staple of the Fox network and
a consistent success as of 2023 Family
Guy has aired a total of 21 seasons and
McFarland has remained a part of the
show's voice cast